he'll welcome to this video I'd say RTO
is the opponent confetti okay queen seon
type of position and transposase
hedgehog to a hedgehog okay well not
necessarily he can still go with d5 with
most people not this one maybe play with
d6 okay III is also interesting yeah
this is probably a little bit on the
simplistic side let's play a more
tactical game let's say we should have
six
chance it's really equal issue really
equal ish I'm a little bit better
developed but that's at first really
Queenie seven maybe just complete um
yeah complete this form I mean I was I
wanted to say is connecting works well
maybe I can do to lose something here
with the with this is six square okay
[Music]
pawn to b5 and night to see success idea
a well-known Lee motif from tons of
games most prominently the game but
vedra Arthur Donna yeah I spotted this
but I also spotted it it's a little bit
difficult to save the night cannot take
two to Queen the aid
think the piece is just lost
okay I didn't see that one oh my god now
anyway is it it's a good o Queen system
I am i doing i should think and not just
play moves come on I'm such a [ __ ] yeah
he's got Queen c7 no immediate no aah
come on let's crazy am such an idiot I'm
such an idiot and I played it's like oh
great this is great you just have a
better position there with white and I
play this like the complete completely
you so that's completely brainless it's
the only way to do such a position away
just have tempo up in a symmetrical
situation it's blunder piece and i
blundered piece and if anything is he
overlooked 24 and then just wanted
oneida 8 i'm not actually using and then
i take and then blunder editors how much
of an idiot idiot can you be here and
crazy that's crazy so it's sam and i
have to try to hold this then and queens
it too and I'm immediately losing
probably maybe I can try for some
fortress
and it's almost impossible to use this
position the area we can just play
whatever and be better with the week
square on c6 great you should play a 5
now ok HOH HOH is not a bad idea either
I mean this position should lose for
white with it's not not totally easy I
think for him to win k mean I my time at
London more material and it's of course
possible that's the way I played it up
to this point I can blunder even more
material so i can check I don't know
that for me it doesn't help I mean f4 is
kind of tempting and 495 now let's do it
let's do it
yes that poses some problems I think it
can actually sometimes just give up f7
and just like run with the king but h3
is also probably a good move here yeah
now he threatens the check here on each
one maybe this here actually Knight g4
is also also part of this pollution
so check it seems King at five time
morning king of five works
nan og for becomes more interesting more
interesting threaten turn yeah okay I
cannot go to you five is the problem as
if I is hanging
[Music]
ok
ok
yeah it was probably and the end I know
air for Hanks again yeah it was an
amazing feat to move to lose his
position really we're just can't it was
kind of funny I because I mean he
thought he was was blundering here off
of the draw okay I went Queen default
and now taking is of course completely
ridiculous you can basically never lose
if you just play a normal move I mean
Queen defaults actually probably making
less sense yeah because we asked yes the
night move I mean should play this or
whatever white is always just a little
bit better in this position as i'm a bit
quicker and this is this is weaker than
than my squares with it some basically
impossible to use and this is just
ridiculous em okay yeah maybe i should
have just stayed instead of trying
something all 95 was drawing okay
because he's in some kind of yeah that's
funny yeah i can't actually give all
that up because this is a mating net and
he has to perpetual then and i didn't
that didn't work yeah unfortunately
there's never night to eat right and I'm
just the position is just to lose you
know let the draw for most irritating of
it I was kind of oh I'm winning that's
why it offers a draw and that made me
overlook a night f8 entirely there
wasn't mindless move right anyway that's
the way to squander away 2400 oh thanks
for watching